[Applause]
greatest ufc journalist of all time
self-proclaimed
not self-proclaimed the people proclaim
me the greatest ufc journalist of all
time the people's journalist i am the
people's journalist i thought you said
it
first no he's the people
he's the people's greatest journalist of
all time the people's greatest ufc
journalist yeah i'm the greatest
journalist of the ufc of all time and
mma it's not just ufc it's mma
of all time of all time fighting sports
ever asked me anything about ufc i'll
tell you right now did you watch the
fights yes and what'd you think that was
phenomenal i predicted this i told you
amanda nunes would get [ __ ] knocked
out or choked out people get mad because
you keep on saying nunes when his nunes
you don't even know how to say it how do
you pronounce it in portuguese
they just have to sound a little bit
more [ __ ] yeah yeah but no i
predicted this was going to happen okay
julianna pena just beast
beast
what did you know why why did you know
she was because she believes in herself
she believes she could do anything okay
the world is her oyster okay all right
and she also has great teeth okay got it
that's how you knew great teeth i just
knew it dude i feel like it was a good
point if you're a fighter with great
teeth you're probably a good fighter you
really i mean it's just the venezuelan
vixen bro
you know what i mean like this is
venezuela like these people already
produce the hottest women on the planet
and there's no food you start feeding
these women
they can do anything yeah they already
produce fat ass big tits beautiful face
beautiful body no food eating cardboard
natural rice oh [ __ ] then you start
giving them real american nutrients
chicago [ __ ] cheese meat bread
unstoppable unstoppable force
it's an unstoppable force a venezuelan
with food cannot be stopped that's a
good idea what did you actually do a
fight that you thought was like i
thought it was so entertaining it was
[ __ ] unbelievable
um yeah i think it was friday night
because of
i think it should have been friday night
just because of the sheer upset
like it was unbelievable
it was so incredible to see like amanda
nunes is nunes
is uh it was so if you were watching the
latest fight it's like so incredibly
dominant like she touches you you go to
bed right yeah and
she touched pena and she walked through
it kept punching through it she was not
scared she called her shot she'd been
calling her out for a while she said
exactly what she was going to do and
then she [ __ ] did it
and when you do that stuff it is just so
impressive so god bless her man and
man that was just so [ __ ] awesome
were you a little bummed to see the end
of the era no and i'm not saying that
she can't come back yeah like i think
she can come back and she just has to be
a little bit more she got into a
firefight another thing was it was it
really interesting we were talking to
ben askren about this and grappling
cardio is different than boxing cardio
okay
so and you saw the same thing happened
in the sec in the uh in the other
co-main event with uh oliveira and porya
but
amanda when she's on her feet this great
striker like she can go for days
striking has all this power but what
happened she got caught in a grapple
with pena and that grappling cardio
ascorin said is different
right like guys who have a super long
gas tank all of a sudden they're on the
ground and they're grappling either jiu
jitsu or wrestling and it just tires
them the [ __ ] out right you saw guys
that can go forever just get absolutely
thoroughly [ __ ] exhausted and i guess
it just requires a different
uh i don't know maybe it just requires
different type of muscle usage and
because of that you gas quicker right i
don't know like a guy like ben asking
you look at his body you're like nah
this guy doesn't have great cardio right
i bet that guy can wrestle for days a
guy like dc you look at his body like
this guy probably doesn't have a great
cardio but that guy can wrestle with
[ __ ] days
right so it is a different ball game and
i think that's going to be
a skill that's going to be utilized to
uh
minimalize the effect of these strikers
i think we're about to be like in a new
evolution of mma
like the sport just keeps evolving it's
crazy because you saw in the second
fight
or in the second code main event but
pourier oliveira i don't know if you
guys saw it did you guys watch that
you watched so it's like
once for like basically the whole what
was it
second round
i think it was like a whole second round
that uh oliveira got dusted on the
ground and just kind of stood over him
and then dustin was just kind of like
holding on because he didn't want it in
the middle of the octagon give
potentially give up his back or do
something sneaky that could because
oliveira is so good at jiu jitsu right
so he's like i'm basically just gonna
hold and get [ __ ] pounded on for the
whole round and then they'll stop it
then we're back on the feed i'll get
back to business but that [ __ ]
taxes you gasses you he came back in the
third he was [ __ ] gassed
right like you even saw it with remember
when izzy fought uh jan bleh
right and john just stayed on top of him
he wasn't even trying to really score
but he was like as long as we're not on
our feet this guy doesn't have an
advantage over me and izzy look ass yeah
yeah right and now it's different he's
coming up 20 [ __ ] pounds fighting a
guy who weighs much more than him and
the guy was just leaning on him the
whole time right but i'd be interested
to see what he has to say like does he
think that grappling actually taxes him
in a different way he's been kickboxing
since [ __ ] what 18 or something like
that he won't get tired of it you'll
never see him get tired throwing strikes
yeah
like just when he in that fight with
gasterum do you remember fifth round
mm-hmm i'm prepared to die yeah was it
just swinging for the fences fifth round
so it's like there's something about
that cardio that's different i mean you
even saw it like
connor anybody who goes up against
khabib once starts holding you
unbelievable that's a rat
something's different about that cardio
so that might be a good strategy used
for the strikers and i wonder if we're
about to be in this new era where like
one of the earlier errors was these jiu
jitsu guys came and they started [ __ ]
tapping these people out right and if
you didn't have any skill with jiu-jitsu
once someone grabbed you was over yeah
they just tangle you up and then find a
way to tweak some part of your body or
get that [ __ ] neck and then it's done
yeah and then what happened is the
strikers started learning enough jujitsu
or wrestling in order to combat the
grappling right and then keep it on the
feet right or these guys that were like
wrestlers were able to keep the jiu
jitsu guys away from them enough and
then developed enough striking where
they could have an advantage right and
then we had this cool era where it was
like the strikers were starting to
dominate that had good wrestling
backgrounds right it was like these
wrestlers that learned really good
striking right and i wonder now if we're
starting to get into this era where it's
like those jiu jitsu guys that was kind
of like been forgotten almost yeah
if these jiu jitsu guys started to get
good enough at striking where their
striking was elite like this charles
oliveira guy like he can bang with you
he can go he can go with you he can
throw but if it goes to the grounds be
careful right because when dustin and
oliveira were swinging on each other
when they were standing up and striking
dustin was winning those exchanges
but dustin knew if this guy gets my back
or if he holds me or anything there's
nothing i can do right
and it's a really good event just like
what happened nate diaz every single
fight like nate diaz could get clipped
go to the ground you can't go to the
ground with him
if your jiu jitsu isn't good right you
can't like you could try to ground and
pound him but if he if he locks you up
now you're giving him the advantage
right it's like what connor would say
just get up right
right it's like i have a bet i would
rather let you get up and recover then
be on the ground and be in a dangerous
position yeah i cannot strike you let's
go here it is so like oliveira is like
even more dangerous with the jujitsu
yeah i wonder if it's it's this kind of
new era where these jiu jitsu guys
finally got elite at striking and now
everybody's gonna have to get their jiu
jitsu up yeah because you can't just
defend now because when you're on your
feet you don't have the same advantage
you used to have
yeah did you watch the sean o'malley
fight yes i love watching him he's great
he's just so fun he's great and i think
joe brought up an interesting thing
about o'malley which was
he's like they're bringing him up in the
same way they bring up boxers yeah
they're doing a great job yeah and
usually actually what i admire about the
ufc is they don't usually do this
is
by the time you're ready to be in the
ufc they figure like you're one of the
best fighters and then we can throw you
in with the wolves right maybe give you
one fight to see where you are but then
eventually we're just going to basically
sink or swim with you right and the ufc
is such an amazing promotional outlet
because they have all the fighters
signed it doesn't matter if you lose
we're going to fight you again we decide
who fights
but they literally would just be like
hey we think you're pretty good we're
going to put you in with a guy who's a
[ __ ] name if you beat him you're
going to skyrocket if you don't we'll
see what happens with you yeah
and that's also a risk you can take when
you're not paying the guys these crazy
numbers yeah if you have
if you have a fighter that's under a
contract where he gets five million
dollars a fight you better make sure he
wins right he's got to be ready
why would you make him uh fight some
really tough wrestling guy that could
potentially hold him down an interesting
fight get him injured like yeah
the model i know it sounds crazy like
i'm capping for the ufc but the model
the pay structure creates more
entertaining fights incentivizes the
entertain because everybody wants to get
the bonuses and allows you to take
fights and lose and keep fighting
right the structure at least but the
threshold they got to be making enough
to compensate what are you punching the
head yes don't get me wrong and i don't
know what those numbers are so i have to
figure out what that's what i'd like to
know yeah but what i hope is that these
people like sean o'malley learn how to
make enough money outside of the sport
with the fame that they're getting from
it
where they can where they can produce
real money it's like
i'm not crying that youtube is not
paying me more money right i'm literally
creating we're literally creating hours
and hours of content for them to put
advertising on and we get a fraction of
those advertising but you know what we
did we went and got our own advertisers
right now if the ufc becomes like ncaa
and limits their ability to get
sponsorship and all this other stuff and
starves out they got that's [ __ ] up
but if they're like yo do your thing go
teach some seminars here do classes
there content here blah blah blah for
this guy be there use the stardom to
create money i just want to fight though
i just want to fight hey this has
changed that's like comics they go i
just want to go up oh yeah that's going
to tell jokes that's cute do you no [ __ ]
we all do yeah you want to tell jokes
for a living well you might have to do a
couple more [ __ ] things
don't be a dinosaur but if you're part
of a promotion like they should be able
to hook it up like if you're a comic
you're just out there on your own not
signed there are some that are able to
do that they just won't reach the same
heights you can do that right but if you
want to find a way to make money and
please believe the bigger your star gets
outside of it the more you command
inside of it yeah so it's this
if you're doing it right it's this whole
self-fulfilling prophecy yeah which to
me is shawn's leverage is that like they
just see him as a star they're like yeah
he's down to play ball like he knows how
to like get people to watch he's good at
pressers like his hair has died like he
knows how to get attention so let's
build him up give him all the fights he
needs and then put him in like the big
money fights and and he's if i'm him i'm
not mad at it because i'm like [ __ ] i
want to risk i want to take a risk
making no money i'll take the risk when
i'm making the real money when i resign
my new contract and i'm getting five
times more than i am for each one of
these fights
i'll i would love to fight the top five
and potentially lose i'll potentially
lose for millions yeah but you want to
be 15-0
of course oh so you said they're
bringing them up like a boxer because
they're giving them easy fights right
now that's what it seems like right yeah
they're they're not throwing them in
with the wolves which is like
traditionally what a lot of times ufc
will do usually
i mean if you look at this guy like
michael chandler who they who they
signed right like
the his first few fights in ufc have
been just [ __ ] savages
i think his first fight was against dan
hangman right
shout out to dan love dan
and uh he was the guy that came to the
las vegas show and was saying that
there's on stage just absolute savage
right
then his next fight is against
um
charles oliveira
right yeah who is the title holder and
then his last fight was again justin
gaichy
it's just savages right savage after
savage after savage so it's like they're
down to play ball but they don't have
anything to lose because they're like
all right if we believe in this guy
we'll keep giving him shots and if he
keeps [ __ ] up these shots then we can
cut him right
yeah
like
people might not like the pay structure
but they cannot deny that the product
is phenomenal and we just have to look
at how much of that has to do with the
pay structure yeah right also this is
not to say that o'malley's fights were
easy
like i don't think like they were maybe
like they weren't objectively like the
hardest but like his fight against chris
moutinho was like
i guess it was easy for him not that one
but like the other fights that he's had
like i mean his fighting in cheeto vera
wasn't easy and chirovera won and that
was a big step up in competition and
then so they brought it back down a
little bit yeah and i think but i found
him i'm not mad at that i'm like yo i
would not be at all pay me if you're
gonna pay me 20 grand for a fight or
whatever the [ __ ] it is then i'm
fighting a 20 grand fighter and i'm
gonna pick them apart and entertain and
do all these things with very little
risk you got to pay me for risk yeah
right you know what i mean like hey get
[ __ ] up exactly anybody's gonna fight
a [ __ ]
for ten thousand dollars like there's no
risk yeah right but ten thousand dollars
to fight rampage
you think it's an indication of other
fighters like yo i gotta come in with
something else
to like offer value to the promotion
so that they have an incentive to want
to build me up i think it's a kid who
grew up on the internet and understands
the game and understands the success
with people and how this [ __ ] works you
know what i mean it came out to the six
nine song yeah so that unreleased like
leaked six nine track oh i thought it
was a i didn't know it was a release
track yeah i thought it came out yet oh
i thought it was just whatever but yeah
i mean i got six nine tattoo i mean it's
like to be honest it's the same way as
like any comic that's either doing
comedy now or coming into comedy is
they're going to see the way that we've
done it and they're going to do that
exact same thing this is just how you
succeed in this this is what it is now
so it's like
you're going to go okay wow what is
shelton's boys doing okay this is it
this is how comedy is done now
and that's just what it is so if you're
a young fighter coming up you're going
to be probably on tick tock you're going
to be on youtube you're going to be
podcasting and going on podcasting the
nilk boys tell you to come out you're
going to [ __ ] come hang out and i
know there's [ __ ] out there
that just want to get in the gym and
bang and that's cool you're just not
going to make as much money yeah or you
it might take you longer because you're
not offering external value to the
promotions yeah and listen the reality
is is like
99 of people just aren't good enough to
be champion but some of you could be
entertaining enough to get a shot yeah
if you're doing anything live you got to
sell tickets and it's hard to do that
with just skill yeah you need some
personality people need to be attached
to you man that's another thing for sean
is that he has a personality and that's
the thing with the ufc personalities
thrive so it's like you don't even have
to win but if you have an engaging
personality and a really good fight
style you'll keep fighting
you'll be a [ __ ] commentator like
they take care of the guys that do good
work for the business like there's one
thing like
you don't have to be the guy who's 20-0
to be one of the commentators yeah you
just got to be interesting
articulate enough
right and an engaging personality that
people want to see yeah
like i don't know i think there's a lot
of opportunity there i'm a person who's
like yo let me see his opportunity like
you got guys like guys who would be
journeyman in boxing making millions of
dollars in the ufc like cerrone
oh yeah with his record people would
call him a journeyman as a boxer right
but in mma he was a [ __ ] star
nate diaz is a superstar yeah
superstar muslim superstar is a
superstar it's like if i'm if i'm not
the best fighter in the gym i'm looking
at the ufc i'm like how do i get in yeah
i don't care like just let me get in get
one crazy knockout
yeah you're w
with the ufc you are one crazy knockout
away from a massive fight yeah
that's true
so and it's the other guys that like
when you're the best you don't really
need it as much you know what i mean
like tomorrow like he doesn't have to be
doing all the antics and all the crazy
[ __ ] and he'll make less money because
of it he yeah but he's already a champ
he's the best i know but it doesn't
matter he needs to fight people he needs
to fight people that will bring those
antics like his payday is going to come
when he's fighting colby and colby's
going to sauce it up his painting is
going to come he's going to fight maz
veda all mozarella's going to spice it
up and be on all the pots you know
kamaru is in the gym he's working and
he's the best and he's undeniable it is
what it is that's the fact but people
are trying to get into a fight with him
100 percent of the bill if he just has
the belt forever he'll just make all the
money from all the other people doing
sure but people won't care to see him
lose it or win it
if they don't personally value him
but they might care about his opponent
so now he's opponent dependent because
whereas
a lot of people wanted to watch floyd
lose just because they hated him yeah i
mean you're foolish to think that people
just care about greatness because
casuals don't care about greatness
casuals care about personality mm-hmm
right like we know that even from our
game
you know what i mean so it's like
the casual is out there for the person
that they've engaged with and that they
love and for whatever reason they
connect with and that might have nothing
to do with how great they are at the
sport
so he's gonna have to rely on the
casuals really loving or hating
his opponent
in order for him to make the most money
and that's fine too because he's got the
leverage since he got the belt them
casual them them characters those
personality driven fighters need to
fight him in order to get the belt right
that's my point as long as he's got the
belt then he's fine he's got exactly and
i think he's gonna have the belt for a
while because he's unbelievable
absolutely but still his biggest payday
will not come from another guy who's
also really skilled that deserves a
fight they'll come from a guy who's got
personality and people gravitate to yeah
like if he fights nate diaz people are
going to tune into that fight
because they love nate diaz and then the
people who are actually students of the
game and really care or can be like oh
my god kamarulisman is the best that's
doing it right now right i need to see
him fight but the way you make the real
money is when my girl is interested in a
fight
you know what i mean when akash goes we
gotta watch yeah yeah like if conor
fights akka is going to watch it i'm
going to watch kamar was jay paul we got
to set it up yo i would be in it you'd
be in yeah and and
we like kumar
personality yeah but jake is going to
bring somebody to it so it's like
honestly if i'm kamal i'm just fighting
[ __ ] that people hate if i want
to be the hero
like who who do people hate the most in
the ufc it's gotta be close enough it
can't just be bums that are crazy i
don't think at this point it matters
i would think if he's just destroying
lower level opponents people would be
like oh he's just fighting bums
i think you get to a level of dominance
where it's like if you're just knocking
all these [ __ ] out you might as
well knock the person out that i don't
like
yeah you know like if i think you're
crazy to think that people wouldn't
watch a jake paul mma fight against
kumar yeah that's insane
but i think people are tuning in they
want to see jake lose that's all i'm
saying as long as they want to see
somebody win or lose
not
skill displayed right that's for the
people who love it
[Applause]